human beings are part symbolic and part
animal there is a dimension to our lives
that is metaphysical and mythological
and which will feel connected with
something larger than ourselves with
something infinite and then there is a
part of us that bleeds and that
defecates we are simultaneously gods and
worms and there is tension there in now
when we live in our bliss and we connect
with our passion when we connect with
our purpose when we are plugged into
something larger than ourselves we feel
an agility and self possession that is
irresistible we are as God's we are like
an airplane in flight with a million
moving parts working together in perfect
harmony and precision to keep this
larger-than-life entity aloft and in
flight think of that agility and self
possession that we feel when we are in
the zone we are in the flow now of
course anytime that we are reminded of
our finitude of our limitations of our
of our of our fleshly casing that is a
kind of existential bummer of the
highest order you know I fell on my
bicycle yesterday and I got a scrape on
my hand and just the wounds just like
being scraped just having to look at
that and to ponder that I am a creature
made of flesh even though I feel like a
mythological metaphysical being and can
contemplate space and time on a scale
just shy of the infinite a creature that
can fall in love a creature that can
experience radiance and
intersubjectivity and consume cinema of
the highest order and probe the
perimeters of his own consciousness in
mind a true psycho not a true soul
sailor simultaneously made of flesh I am
divine yet I am food for worms this is
due this is the hopeless duality of man
right this is the existential terror the
existential bummer the vivid intensity
of our condition is something that I am
not sure I can even cope with you know I
feel an agitation a collective
existential agitation to be a being that
wants to soar ready to be like Jonathan
Livingston Seagull flowing through the
skies of line through the landscape and
yet to feel grounded by breath grounded
by by
grounded by this like entropic
embodiment right oh my god it's a bummer
it's a bummer but I take I take
inspiration from buckminster fuller when
he tells us that even though life is
bound by entropy life is still
anti-entropic life moves away from
entropy and towards greater complexity
and organization and then from life
sprouts technology and we go from the
born to the made and perhaps with mind
and life and technology we will extend
our scaffoldings of mind beyond the
casings of flesh and we might engender
godhood right and God as Dylan Thomas
says do not go quietly into that good
night but rage against the dying of the
light perhaps in this quote is the
summation of the human opus the human
opera that we will not go quietly that
we are here to do gauger oh my god
that's that's the human situation and
that's what keeps me going
you